let me tell you a little story today I
was writing some code and it didn't do
what I expected I expected it to do
that's that's the story in the video
thank you come again more of a real
story I just kind of got through school
I don't know it's been like five six
months ago since I graduated for CS
future science now that I'm actually
working in in a company and writing code
with a company and other people use it
and stuff and it's like it needs to be
dependable yeah you need to test your
code thoroughly so you spend a lot of
time writing test cases and thinking up
a lot of different scenarios it might be
used in in making tests with those
scenarios why is this important in also
I didn't really know how to do it other
than okay so I don't know I write a main
that uses the code I wrote or something
and this has been really really valuable
to me since I started my job in the real
world no longer coding for a professor
see these projects they give you in
school they don't really matter that
much you can kind of wing them and as
long as they're good enough to pass
really all right but that doesn't work
in the real world world if they're just
like if they have a bunch of errors they
don't pass at all it's like you got to
go back to the drawing board and spend
more time on it it has to be has to work
right otherwise nobody can use it and I
think maybe some schools do teach this
better than others but if you have the
cases that it needs to pass like and
then you write the code towards it
you're good I have one class that did
this except it wasn't like you would
think it was they did it in the most
overwhelming nonsensical way ever it
wasn't it wasn't even comprehendible and
I don't think I think maybe like one
student understood it in the old class
so I think a lot of professors go way
too far with this stuff and they just
need to provide a few simple cases for
people to get to get kind of used to
doing it but like the first time I had
to actually pass a bunch of test cases
in one of my classes it was like
eighty test cases and I was like what do
these even do and they weren't just the
same thing they were like I don't know
it was just overwhelming he you should
start with I don't know say your first
few projects every professor should hand
you some some input and say he expects
this output that would make a lot more
sense
so today something happened where I was
rewriting some code and and doing you
know just making some changes and
everything seemed pretty good except one
case was failing and then a little later
Illinois and another case was failing
and soon i isolated it to certain five
cases that were failing and then i
looked at all those functions and all of
them used something in them and isolated
it down and corrected the thing and then
all the tests pass but what you don't
know is there were about forty I think I
think was forty nine other tests that
passed fine so it was just these five so
it was important to cover all your bases
when you're writing test code
I don't know what it is I don't know if
it's just me but I don't think it's just
me because usually when I experienced
something I realized it about everybody
is experiencing the same thing so if you
want to see a video about writing test
cases leave a comment and I hope this
video helps someone out there peace out
okay